العسكري والاستراتيجي نرحب بك العميد
الياس استهداف العمق الروسي بالمسيرات
اصبح
مشهدا شبه يومي قراءتكم العسكريه في ذلك
ازدهار عندما تتكرر هذا يعني انها اصبحت
سياسه او استراتيجيه ومقاربه جديده اثنين
الكثره يعني ان هناك وسائل وتوفر هذه
المسيرات لضرب الداخل ثلاثه تظهر مدى
هشاشه الدفاعات الجويه خاصه عن العاصمه
حيث مراكز الثقل الاساسيه يعني والوزارات
وحتى مراكز الاعمال اربعه هذا يفرض ضغط
على
القياده الروسيه والدفاعات الجويه ولكن لن
يكون العامل الحاسم تقول وزاره
الاستخبارات او تقول الاستخبارات
البريطانيه انه من الممكن ان تكون هذه
المسيرات تنطلق من الداخل الروسي هذا امر
يعني يعني يجب اثباته في مكان ما ولكن هذا
امر مهم جدا في ظل التعثر على الجبهه 900
كلم في جنوب وشرق اوكرانيا هنا سؤال صيد
الياس فعليا عسكريا واستراتيجيا ما الذي
تحقق هذه الضربات في العمق في تحديدا
العاصمه موسكو ما الذي لا يزال
الاوكرانيون يرجونه من هذه المسيرات
سفيان هي نقل ارض المعركه من الداخل الى
داخل اوكرانيا الى داخل الروسي اثنين
الازهار
للشعب الروسي ان العمليه ليست عمليه
عسكريه محدوده خاصه انما هي قد تستهدف
العمق الاساسي اذا او المعامله بالمثل هي
عمل سيكولوجي اكثر منه عمل عسكري لماذا
لانه المسافه التي تحلق فيها هذه المسايره
والهدف والضرر الذي تحدثه والحموله او
الراس الحربي هي بسيطه وهي خارج اطار
المعركه الاساسيه اليوم المعركه الاساسيه
سفيان هي المعركه على الارض على الارض في
اوكرانيا ومن يسيطر على الارض يسيطر على
المعركه ونتائج المعركه هذا امر هذا كما
يقال هي عمليه نقل ارض المعركه الى الداخل
وفي نفس الوقت خوض المعركه من ضمن الهجوم
الاوكراني في ضوء المعارك المستمره بين
الطرفين خطوه روسيه لافته وهي اقاله رئيس
اركان القوات الجويه واستبداله باخر هل
لذلك اي دلالات في هذا التوقيت العميد
ازدهار لا اعتقد انها شيء مهم لانه
الجنرال سيروفيكين هو قائد جو عين لقياده
بريه وهذا امر يعني مستغرب كان مقربا من
بريجوجين هو الذي خاض او قرر الانسحاب من
مدينه خرسون
وقال بالدفاع وهذا الخط يعني 900 كيلومتر
يقال عنه انه خط سيروفيكين وهو الذي اقترح
العمليات والقصف الاستراتيجي لكل البنى
التحتيه التي لا تزال مستمره لاوكرانيا
هذا الامر يعني ليس بشيء علاقته سيئه مع
وزاره الدفاع من هنا تغييره امر عادي
وطبيعي سيدي الياس نقطه مهمه اخرى يعني
وهذه الاتهامات الاوكرانيه لروسيا بقصف
مستودعات للحبوب وعلى ما يبدو يعني
استراتيجيه التركيز على الموانئ النهريه
تحديدا كيف تفهم هذه الجزئيه
عاملان اساسيان سفيان اولا اوكرانيا تريد
ان يكون هناك كوريدور مهم باتجاه تركيا
اثنين البديل لاوديسا هو اما في البر وهذا
امر صعب جدا الكلفه كبيره والوقت طويل
الملاحه النهريه هو استعداد لنقل الحبوب
الاوكرانيه الى دوله الى رومانيا ومن ثم
شحنها وهذا امر لا تريده روسيه قصف هذه
يعني
انهاء اي عمليه واي امل بتصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه
اشكرك العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
الاستراتيجي كنت معنا من بيروت